أين توجد خطوط السيطرة هذه بالضبط
كما يطلق عليها الليلة مع
احتفاظ روسيا الآن بما يقرب من خمس مساحة
البلد ، هذا صحيح تمامًا
وهو خامس البلد ، إنه
بحجم مسيسيبي هو المنطقة
التي يسيطر عليها الروس  أوكرانيا ، لذا
إذا نظرنا إلى الخريطة هنا ، فإن ما نراه
هو منطقة تمتد من خاركيف إلى أسفل بهذه
الطريقة على طول الطريق نحو كيراسان ،
فهذه منطقة سيطرة يمتلكها
الروس وهم في الأساس يقاتلون
الأوكرانيين في هذه المنطقة  لأن ما
يتعين عليهم فعله هو أن يكونوا قادرين
على السيطرة على هذه المنطقة من أجل تحقيق
أحد أهداف الحرب الرئيسية
لفلاديمير بوتين وهو السيطرة على منطقة دونباس
، فلنتحدث قليلاً عن هذه
المدينة الرئيسية سيفيرو دونيتسك أخبرنا
لماذا  من المهم جدًا الآن ما
يحدث هناك ، لذلك هذا ذئب مهم
لأن دونيتسك الحبوب
هو حقًا النقطة الأساسية
هنا في هذا الجزء من منطقة لوهانسك ،
منطقة لوهانسك هي الشمال  الجزء
الأخير من منطقة دونباس ، الجزء الوحيد
الذي يسيطر الأوكرانيون على هذه المنطقة هو
هذا الجزء هنا
مباشرة حول سيبيريا دونيتسك
وشمال مدينة بوباسنا مباشرة ،
ما يعنيه هذا هو أنه في سيفيرو دونيتسك ، يعد
هذا التقاطع المهم واحدًا من
المناطق التي
سيحتاج الأوكرانيون فيها إما للاحتفاظ بهذا إذا كانوا
يريدون إبقاء هذا تحت السيطرة ولكن المشكلة الأخرى
التي يواجهونها هي أنه من السهل
جدًا على الروس عزلهم في هذه
المرحلة بالذات إذا فعل الروس ذلك
القوات الأوكرانية  هنا تخاطر
بأن تكون محاصراً وستكون هذه
مشكلة كبيرة بالنسبة لهم ، لذا ما
هو الخطر في اعتقادك أن هذه
القوات الأوكرانية محاصرة هناك
ذئب مرتفع للغاية ويجب على الأوكرانيين
توخي الحذر الشديد للحفاظ على قواتهم إذا
لم يفعلوا ذلك.  من أجل الحفاظ على قواتهم
، سيخسرون جزءًا كبيرًا من
جيشهم وسيكون ذلك
كارثيًا لجهودهم الحربية ، لذلك
تعتقد أن هناك نافذة محدودة الآن
حيث  من المحتمل أن ينسحب الكراينيون
نعم أه إذا استخدموا هذه المناطق
هنا مباشرةً وإذا ألقيت نظرة مباشرة من
خلال هذه المنطقة ، فلا يزال لديهم
طريق مفتوح للعودة إلى
المناطق الخاضعة للسيطرة الأوكرانية إذا
فعلوا ذلك ، فستتاح لهم فرصة
حفظ هذا الجزء  من جيشهم
سيكون أمرًا حاسمًا إذا لم يفعلوا
ذلك ، فهم يخاطرون بفقدان هذا الجيش
وهذا بالطبع سيكون ضربة كبيرة لهم